JAKE ARCHIBALD: In
five years time,
what is your idea of Web heaven,
Web hell-- assuming everything
goes right,
everything goes wrong?
PAUL LEWIS: Yeah, I'm going
with utopian and dystopian,
because it feels more
"Blade Runner"-ish.
JAKE ARCHIBALD: Yes.
Oh, great film, yeah.
PAUL LEWIS: No.
It's not a good film.
It's a terrible film.
I don't even know
why I brought it up.
I don't even like the movie.
I watched it, right?
It's one of those movies.
I'm one of these people
that people go, oh, you've
never seen that movie?
You are terrible human being.
JAKE ARCHIBALD: I'm
still getting past
I don't like "Blade Runner."
PAUL LEWIS: Yeah.
Right.
This does come back into that.
There are loads of
movies where you
get told that it's a classic
and a must watch, ooh, all that.
So you then go, fine.
All right.
Fine.
I'll buy it.
It's $5.99 on Play, HD
version, because you've
got to go HD, because whatever.
JAKE ARCHIBALD: Of course.
Rules are rules.
PAUL LEWIS: Rules are rules.
And you do it.
And you sit down to
watch it, and you've
got everything perfect.
It's all set up.
And you watch it and you
think, this is pathetic.
This is a rubbish, rubbish
movie. "Highlander",
also terrible, with Sean
Connery's-- honestly,
I've never heard a more
abysmal Spanish accent.
(IMITATING SEAN
CONNERY) "My name
is Juan Sanchez
Villa Lobos Ramirez."
You're not Spanish--
JAKE ARCHIBALD: No, no!
Stop it!
Stop, stop, stop!
You're trying to say that
"Blade Runner" is bad
because "Highlander" is bad--
PAUL LEWIS: No, no, no.
JAKE ARCHIBALD:
You can't do that.
That's not allowed.
PAUL LEWIS: I'm saying
there's a principle at play
here that nostalgia
applies to movies.
You bring it back in to your
"Blade Runner's" and you
look at it, and you go,
that's just not a good movie,
with Rutger Hauer going--
walking around, trying
to take out Harrison Ford.
JAKE ARCHIBALD: It's
got Harrison Ford in it.
PAUL LEWIS: Yeah.
Now I'm told that I watched
the wrong cut of that movie,
because I watched
the director's cut.
JAKE ARCHIBALD: Yeah, because
you watched "Highlander",
clearly.
[LAUGHTER]
PAUL LEWIS: No, I watched--
JAKE ARCHIBALD: The worst
thing about "Blade Runner"
was the Spanish accent
by Sean Connery.
[GARBLED SEAN CONNERY MUMBLING]
No.
PAUL LEWIS: What was that?
What was that?
JAKE ARCHIBALD: That
was my impersonation
of your impersonation of Sean
Connery's Spanish accent.
PAUL LEWIS: That was perfect.
Absolutely flawless.
Anyway, in any case, you
come back to it and you go,
"Blade Runner" is
not a good movie.
And as I say, I watched the
director's cut, which I thought
would be the ultimate cut,
the one that's worth watching.
Turn's out apparently I
watched the wrong one.
Any movie that has enough
cuts to have a wrong one
is a movie that clearly
they couldn't make good.
JAKE ARCHIBALD: "Star Wars?"
PAUL LEWIS: No,
they all got better,
apart from the bit where
Han Solo went over the back
of Jabba the Hutt's--
JAKE ARCHIBALD: Yeah, come on.
PAUL LEWIS: But anyway,
dystopian, utopian Web.
Let's bring that back in.
JAKE ARCHIBALD:
I don't know if I
can trust your answer anymore.
PAUL LEWIS: No.
But flawless.
My take on this is perfect.
JAKE ARCHIBALD: So
your Web dystopia.
Five years in future, the
Web is a dark horrible place
because all the things that
are starting to happen now
have just worse, or things
that could happen now
have got worse.
PAUL LEWIS: Then you're
the only-- every time
you hit a URL the
first thing you see
is a door slam, where
you're told to download,
and you can't skip past it
for at least 10 seconds.
JAKE ARCHIBALD: Yep, yep.
Or until you say
to your phone, I
promise to download the app
later, it has an audio feature.
PAUL LEWIS: Well, no.
That's the only way you get
to the Web experience is
by forcing a download
or something.
Then when the only people
who can build for the Web
are the elites.
JAKE ARCHIBALD:
Like the Avengers.
PAUL LEWIS: Yeah,
like the Avengers.
The Web Avengers.
JAKE ARCHIBALD: Tony
Stark is the only person
who can build websites.
PAUL LEWIS: Essentially,
yeah, because the tooling
has become so complex and
complicated that only an AI can
build for the Web.
What else I think would
be absolutely terrible?
Everything just runs abysmally,
because the frameworks are
so heavy, and the tooling is
so heavy that nothing actually
runs well.
JAKE ARCHIBALD: And
I think that there's
sort of knock on effect of that
is that if the Web dies, then
you're going to see--
we have a problem
today with the amount
of operating systems
we have with mobiles.
And it shouldn't be like that.
Because now if you want to
start in the mobile space,
you have to have a huge
app ecosystem already.
And that's not going to happen.
So I think that problem gets
worse if the Web weakens.
PAUL LEWIS: Yeah, I agree.
I think it's interesting
that because you've
got these operating
systems and what's
going to naturally
happen is you're
going to want these apps
to start communicating
with each other, or
link to each other,
or in some other way be a
sort of streaming experience
or something like that.
And you just kind of
go, that's the Web.
What you're trying to emulate
is potentially the Web.
JAKE ARCHIBALD: There's
XKCD about that.
So much imagine if an app
could be dynamically loaded,
and there was some
easy way to transfer it
from one person to another.
Yeah, it's the Web.
PAUL LEWIS: It's the Web.
What we need is the Web to
just continue to get stronger
and to be a part of
this overall story.
I don't think it's the
only part of the story.
I think we disagree on that.
But I do think it's
one very strong
and-- it's a pillar of
modern digital worlds.
JAKE ARCHIBALD: So
Web utopia, then.
Five years time, everything's
going brilliantly.
PAUL LEWIS: Well, you
can answer that one.
Because I've done the dystopia.
I'm quite--
JAKE ARCHIBALD: You're the
downer, along with your I
don't like "Blade Runner"
because it's "Highlander",
"Highlander", "Highlander".
PAUL LEWIS: It's rubbish.
Because it's rubbish.
The plot took two hours--
JAKE ARCHIBALD: I don't
want to get into it, mate.
Five years time,
utopia on the Web.
PAUL LEWIS: Utopia
on the Web, go on.
JAKE ARCHIBALD:
Utopia on the Web.
Five years time.
I think we'll see the
apps that you and I use
today that are native will
be done just on the Web,
like the Twitter clients,
like the Facebook clients,
like what other apps do I use?
Hangouts.
These things can be done
just through the Web,
and you write it once, and it's
working on multiple platforms.
That's the utopia.
Because we're getting
really close there
with [? Asamjest ?].
This is one of the
things that I know
a browser is better at than us.
So I thought I would say
that's the utopia, just
the Web being the first answer,
and native being the exception.
[MUSIC PLAYING]